Now what I want you to do is write for me the code for the function solve.
Solve takes an unfilled formula with letters in it,
and if it can find a solution in which you can fill in all the digits,
it returns the string with the digits filled in properly.
If not, it should return None.
Put your code here.
You can assume that we already have the correct definition of what
a valid filled-in formula is.
You can assume that we have a function called "fill_in" that I'm not showing yet.
Fill_in takes a formula and generates a collection of all the possible filling ins of the letters.
You pass it the string ODD plus ODD equals EVEN,
and it passes you back first string filled in with, say, a 1 for the O and a 2 for the Ds and so on.
Then the next string filled in with different numbers filling in each of the possible digits,
and so on and so on.